how's it going bros my name is today
we're going to play Star Wars
Battlefront imagine being inside epic
Star Wars battle that's pretty cool I
play this with Marty I was really fun
video but I thought we place a
multiplayer online I never play with a
controller first-person shooters all
right so be patient with me if I don't
make a complete fool out of myself I'll
be happy so this is drop zone game mode
which basically means you have to defend
the drop zone if your name is PIP I
however you play for Kady getting the
objective that's for losers I'm just
kidding oh god what is this ah I just
fell inside a nipple Oh Oh God
I think I almost killed a guy oh we see
a life how is he'll live I am a true
stormtrooper at heart everyone is
running through there no one is ah
nipple again damn these are the biggest
threat of the Star Wars universe oh god
they're shooting
did I get him I think I got him there it
is look at that guy hi hi hi there he'll
assist that you stole my kill me oh I'll
just throw this in see what happened oh
I hit someone Oh Oh God
I can't handle I kill the top player did
you see that huh you didn't steal that
one did yet oh oh oh oh double kill
I'm the best player in the universe
clearly you skate parties under our
control your leader will be most pleased
lord Vader will be most pleased I'm
ashamed
my god stop getting my kills
oh hello go mine
yes that's what I'm talking about
whoo I'm so good at games that escape
pod is on altitude you sneaky son of a
Snooper that's right you Snoopy Snoop
Dogg oh my god they're all after all
here
haha MLG Oh God
yes
killing it
no no that sneaky son of a-- damn it ah
I was gonna get one this is fun I'm
enjoying this that was a good game
good match see if I had a keyboard right
now don't even don't even get me started
okay this is the map from the third
movie Wow don't even look at me look at
that look at me that escape pod is about
to fall into Imperial hands we can't let
that happen
I'm so focused my God look at that
flawless aim gets gets the ladies every
time they are fun is they're so
addicting that's the problem
hey hey hey hey
blow another pod in indict Linda ha ha
ha oh god that's embarrassing oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god it's the
worst thing I ever seen oh hello oh god
don't panic
hi panic ha ha ha god damnit Oh Santa
Claus is coming to town baby
ha ha ha ha look at my house
help me oh hello
huh what what what what what what
hacks hacks
what
dammit god dammit
I tried I tried I tried okay okay and
you level drop zone ice cream felt like
oh whoa that's really pretty
I know why I want to smell a dozen I
always smell good
hey Frank Frank it's me Frank
oh did we kill each other at the same
time is that possible
Jesus Christ man you scared me oh this
is so creepy
it looks beautiful it feels like I'm in
a cave oh damn
scales identify the position of another
escape oh come on it as soon as possible
Worthen hahaha
Oh God oh there to make sin God no he
saw me number one can we do it bro
assured everywhere he's nine Jesus
yay whoa yeah good game good game
here to pie first time playing the game
I'm pretty proud it was fun
I did try hard extremely but hey it's a
video game what are you gonna do Hey
look at that I'm pretty proud I
recommend it check it out I'll leave a
link to in the description and it's the
euro Star Wars and why not getting the
Star Wars mood it really feels like it
pays well respect to the franchise so
that's it for me thank you both for
watching and as always stay awesome
jetpacks for man's yeah